all right we have one more super sweet
story to end the hour y'all this is what
I'm
liking so it's heartbreaking when kids
have to cope with grown-up challenges as
adults all we can do is try to make it a
little easier for them that's exactly
the purpose of an Atlanta organization
that brings music to kids dealing with
illness injuries or special needs
children take lessons they write and
record music even put on their own
performances uh from songs for kids
Foundation let's everybody Welcome the
founder Josh riffkin what's up
man nice to meet you thank you for
joining us so explain more about what
songs for kids does so we've been going
for 17 years originally songs for kids
we predominantly did bedside
performances with kids and children's
hospitals and a lot of rock concerts at
the hospitals and then six years ago we
uh added our songs for kids Center in
downtown Atlanta and at the center kids
with illnesses injuries and disabilities
can come on down and take any musical
Journey they want so if you want to
write and record music we've got a
studio if you want to perform and be a
singer we've got a full Stage Sound and
lights if you just want to watch and
hang out if you want to touch a bunch of
stuff and buttons and drum machines and
feel that sensory connection you can do
that it's anything you want and you get
paired with one of our songs for kids
mentors to go on this journey and it's
all free oh that's incredible
cuz a lot of people can't afford stuff
like that so you have a special event
coming up one I am quite flattered by
can you tell everybody what it is every
Kelly Clarkson song everfest is
happening in a month
now 23 Songs it includes all of the
holiday classics all of the besides all
of the Duets every album deluxe version
Editions 14 hours it's unbelievable and
it's all happening over two consecutive
days at this festival with 110 of our
kids a that's so cool
man that's so cool everybody be every
Kelly Clarks and song everfest which is
the greatest title ever takes place in
Atlanta January 13th and 14th y'all got
to go online for Ticket go to show up
that's so cool man thank you so much
Josh I'm so flattered and honored I'm
liking your post right now but that's
not all our season long partner pilot
pin makers of precise the go-to pin of
the Kelly Clarkson show want to help you
on your mission so they're writing a
check to the songs for kids foundation
for $1,000 and
hey I'm
gonna I'm GNA I'm going to throw in some
money too because you're like honoring
me so I'm gon to give yall $5,000 so
it's $6,000 total thank you so much and
thank you to all our guests our Lily
James Christopher Bry Edo Haven and
Olivia Rodrigo once again y'all have a
great day if it's not
[Music]
[Applause]
changing thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home